[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory for today's video
i'm going to be continuing with what you
guys seem to enjoy
and making a ranking video however this
is a different sort of ranking video
because it doesn't concern the wizards
or witches of the magical world
in fact it doesn't really concern
humanoids at all
today i'm going to be ranking the most
powerful intimidating
daunting creatures of the magical world
now in a world full of magic it should
come as no surprise that there are some
powerful creatures out there and we're
even able to catch a glimpse of some of
them in the books and films
trolls giants dragons these are all
featured in the films and often their
pal was put on display
in totality however there are a lot of
powerful creatures that never really
made it into the books or films
or appeared very little and i want to
highlight some of those creatures
this list was hard to compile and there
were many creatures that
nearly made the cut after watching i
implore you to share your own top 10
with me without further ado let's jump
into the top 10 most powerful creatures
in the wizarding world
number 10 lethal folds the etymology
behind the name lethal fold is quite
sinister
as lethal fold comes from two roots
lethal variation of bleedum which is
latin for death
annihilation and ruin as well as fold
which likely alludes to the creature's
cloaked appearance
the latherfold resembles a black cloak
roughly half an inch thick
and appears slightly thicker if the
creature has recently digested a victim
it glides along surfaces in an unknown
form of locomotion
in search of its prey humans it attacks
at night when the target is asleep
by suffocating and then digesting it the
lethal fold is a truly dangerous magical
beast
they are extremely aggressive violent
and even carnivorous
luckily the lethal fold is found only in
tropical climates so as long as you
don't go on holiday
you should be safe from them number nine
werewolf the werewolf is considered to
be a category
5x creature by the ministry of magic
meaning that they are impossible to
domesticate
reason with and equally dangerous to
wizard kind werewolves suffer from
lycanthropy
a condition which forces them to
transform into their violent form the
first sign of a full moon
notable werewolves from the series
include remus lupin and fenrir greyback
however lupin contains his condition
somewhat with the wolf spain potion
while in their werewolf form werewolves
have no awareness of who they are
interacting with
this means that even the friends and
allies of a werewolf aren't safe
during a full moon furthermore when they
revert back to their regular form
they will have no recollection of the
terrible actions they made werewolves
are powerful creatures
capable of widespread destruction and
for that reason i feel they are
deserving of this spot on the list
number eight acromentula acromantulas
are basically giant spiders
so if you suffer from arachnophobia aka
the fear of spiders then this one might
be number one on your list
if you'll remember the most notable
acromantula from the series is aragog
hagrid's old pet and the reason for his
expulsion from hogwarts
like werewolves acromanculars are
classified as a category 5x beast by the
ministry of magic
and this is for good reason it has been
expressed that the leg span of
acromanculars can be as large as 15 feet
which makes them a bit more intimidating
than your average house spider
additionally they have eight black eyes
thick black hair giant peta palps which
they use to eat their prey
and highly toxic venom not only that but
acromanculars are sentient and
highly intelligent even capable of human
speech
number 7. giants giants are incredibly
powerful creatures that tend to live out
their lives and tribes
completely separate from the rest of the
wizarding community they are smarter
than trolls
but stupider than humans and their
innate bloodthirsty nature has typically
resulted in their own population control
the secret to giant's power is in their
name they are giant
in fact they are larger than almost any
other magical creature equal in physical
strength of dragons
and highly resistant to spells giants
have been known to side with voldemort
as we saw in both the first and second
wizarding wars
however despite their immense power they
do have an achilles heel
their eyes the eyes of giants are much
more vulnerable to spells
attacks and this is how the good guys
are able to take them out this obvious
vulnerability is the only reason that
they aren't higher on the list
number six dementor if you've watched
read harry potter then you should know
this next creature well
the dementor dementors are cloaked
creatures that are three meters tall
with dark grey scabby skin
they are truly foul creatures that
represent unhappiness and despair and
they are frequently known to be the
guards of azkaban prison
ensuring that all the darkest witches
and wizards inside do not escape
dementors are among the phallus
creatures that walk this earth they
infest the darkest filthiest places
they glory and decay and despair they
drain peace hope and happiness out of
the air around them
even muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
dementor and every good feeling
every happy memory will be sucked out of
you if it can the dementor will feed on
you long enough to reduce you to
something like itself
soulless and evil you'll be left with
nothing but the worst experiences of
your life
dementors can strip you of your soul and
leave you just a shell of a person
and that kind of power can't be ignored
however their achilles heel
is the patronus charm as it is a
positive light force that represents
everything that they aren't
as a result they are repelled by its
presence this means that as long as the
witch wizard knows how to use a patronus
charm then they are
safe from dementors number five phoenix
phoenixes are a little unassuming when
compared to other creatures on this list
largely due to their size a more
approachable look they are a little more
inviting than say
an eight-legged giant spider or werewolf
with its teeth out however that doesn't
mean that they aren't more powerful
the most notable phoenix from the harry
potter story is of course dumbledore's
loyal phoenix companion
forks a phoenix is a bird with magical
properties
large and coloured red and gold they can
carry very heavy loads and their tears
have healing powers
on their burning days phoenix has burst
into flames and are reborn from the
ashes
okay so why phoenix is so powerful this
is actually quite a long list
first of all they're immortal when the
phoenix dies it bursts into flames
and it ceases to exist but not for long
after no time at all a phoenix will then
be reborn from its own ashes
next the tears of phoenix have extremely
powerful healing properties
able to save even those who are at the
brink of death next the phoenix has
somewhat of an immunity to magic
we see this when forks fights the
basilisk as he is seemingly unaffected
by the basilisks gaze
next phoenixes have sharp talons which
are no joke when it comes to clawing at
enemies
and lastly phoenix feathers are used to
craft some of the most powerful one
cause
yes they're a little less intimidating
than some of the others on this list but
they are certainly powerful
number four thunderbird you may not have
heard of a thunderbird before but they
are extremely powerful magical birds
that eclipse even the powers of the
fabled phoenix
like the phoenix and its association to
the element of fire
thunderbirds more closely resonate with
aspects of thunder and lightning
though not explicitly stated i suspect
that the two mythical birds are related
in some way
thunderbirds can command the weather and
create powerful targeted storms whenever
they want
additionally they are immense in size
have incredible strength and possess
huge powerful talents
like the phoenix their feathers can be
taken and used in a wand core
thunderbird calls are said to be
particularly powerful at transfiguration
number three basilisk you may remember
the basilisk from the chamber of secrets
they are enormous
serpentine creatures that were
originally created by a dark wizard by
the name of herper the fowl
though commonly their original creation
is wrongfully credited to hogwarts
founder salazar slytherin
though southern created his own this was
not the original basilisk that herpo had
created of the many fearsome beasts and
monsters that roam our land
there is none more curious or more
deadly than a basilisk known also as the
king of serpents
this snake which may reach gigantic size
and live many hundreds of years
is born from a chicken's egg hatched
beneath a toad its methods of killing
are most wondrous
for aside from its deadly and venomous
fangs the basilisk has a murderous stare
and all who are fixed with the beam of
its eye shall suffer instant death
spiders flee before the basilisk fort is
their mortal enemy and the basilisk
flees only
from the crowing of the rooster which is
fatal to it basilisks are gigantic
powerful and immune to a lot of magic
not only that they possess giant fangs
protective scales
and a gaze that can kill you instantly
the basilisk in the film was defeated by
harry with the help of fawkes
however i'm of the impression that 9
times out of 10 the battle would have
gone in the basilisk's favor
harry got lucky really lucky number 2
dragons
i'm sure you knew that dragons would
appear somewhere on the list but i bet
you didn't know where and when
dragons pop up in the harry potter films
quite a bit and are frequently referred
to as some of the most powerful
creatures in existence
dragons are giant winged fire-breathing
beasts that incite fear in the hearts of
even the bravest witches and wizards
they bear the potential to be extremely
destructive
and they are even classified as category
5x by the ministry of magic
this classification means they are known
to kill witches and wizards
and are either extremely difficult to or
impossible to domesticate
we see or hear mentions of dragons pop
up constantly throughout the books and
films
and they are an integral part of the
series one important thing worth
mentioning
however is there are many types of
dragons and some are more powerful than
others
in my opinion the most powerful dragon
of them all is the hungarian horntail
followed closely by the ukrainian
ironbelly the horntail is enormous
and has a lizard-like appearance along
with bronze horns spikes that protrude
from its long tail
and yellow eyes with vertical pupils it
is known to have one of the longest fire
breathing ranges that can scorch you
from 50 feet away the hungarian horntail
was also used in hogwarts as one of the
guardians of the cursed vaults
i think the dragons are more than
deserving of this position on the list
number one noondoo last but certainly
not least we have
the noondoo the noondoo is scarcely
mentioned and that's probably for good
reason
as they are perhaps the most destructive
and powerful creatures of them all when
untamed
though not as big as giants dragons or
basilisks noondoos are nonetheless
considered by many witches and wizards
to be the most dangerous creature in
existence
in fact no noondoo has ever been
defeated by fewer than 100
sorcerers which in my opinion makes the
noondo the clear number one on this list
for some perspective a dragon will
usually require about 10 sorcerers to
subdue
noondoos somewhat resemble lions and
though we aren't exactly sure of their
size
we do know that they are massively fast
resistant to most magic
and possess the ability to breathe
toxins that can clear entire villages
the only weakness that a nunu has and
i'm not sure that you can even call it a
weakness is that they actually
can be tamed as newt's commander was
reportedly able to obtained a young one
and that concludes the list what do you
guys think this list was hard to make
and it was even harder to justify some
of the rankings but i did my best
what order would you put these creatures
in what substitutions would you make
what's your top 10 list let me know in
the comments section
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live
you